when we're talking about a potential
breakthrough in the race for treatments
for the corona virus dr. Anthony foul
she is expressing hope today about a
drug call from des aver which could be
used on patients hospitalized with the
virus Anthony it's being tested now Gail
at the National Institutes of Health
although we're still early in that
process dr. foutch he made his
announcement in the Oval Office Ben
Tracy is at the White House Ben what
exactly do we know about this drug well
good morning first off we should say
this is not a cure this is not a vaccine
but in a clinical trial this drug does
seem to shorten the recovery time for
patients who are hospitalized with
coronavirus now dr. Fauci says it's
quite good news he even compared reading
the data the other night to what it was
like when they first started to find
drugs to treat HIV back in the 1980s the
data shows that REM Divya has a
clear-cut significant positive effect in
diminishing the time to recovery dr.
Anthony Fauci calls the drug rim des
aveer the new standard of care after a
clinical trial showed it can block
coronavirus and speed recovery time
hospitalized patients who took the drug
recovered in 11 days compared to 15 for
those given a placebo a 31% improvement
although a 31% improvement doesn't seem
like a knock out 100% it is a very
important proof of concept but the drug
made by california-based Gilead Sciences
had a very small impact on the death
rate and the study still needs to be
reviewed as more people and more
companies President Trump who has been
criticized for promoting unproven
coronavirus treatments at a surprisingly
measured response
it's the beginning it means you build on
it I love that as a building block the
drug is not yet approved but the
president wants the FDA to do so as soon
as possible we would like to see very
quick approvals especially with things
at work President Trump is now replacing
his daily briefings on the virus with
events that focus on the economy meeting
with CEOs of hotel chains in restaurants
Wednesday the president says he wants
the
entry back open even without a vaccine
because he's convinced the virus will
disappear without a vaccine sir why do
you think the virus will just be gone
it's going to be eradicated now medical
experts have warned that it will take at
least a year to 18 months to develop a
vaccine but CBS News has learned that
the Trump administration is trying to do
something called Operation warp speed to
fast-track the development of a vaccine
Tony all right Ben Tracy Fores Ben thank
you very much